on arrive on agit bien malin celui qui
du premier coup trouve le lavoir seul un
abreuvoir pour aiguiser la curiosité du
touriste vers ce drôle de bâtiments
entièrement fermé une sorte d'écrou
anonyme et il faut bien le dire un peu
triste vie c'est depuis plus d'un siècle
dans la mémoire des habitants
à l'intérieur pour les pour les gens
pensent qu'on était c'était une piste
cyclable
qui n'a pas fait le tour du lavaur avec
le vélo nous fera une démonstration
le vélodrome d'autrefois ne se visite
pas trop dangereux le lavoir un comble
souffre d'infiltrations multiples
certains se demandent si la végétation
ne tient pas les murs désormais plus que
les piliers aux veines apparentes
c'est là toute la magie et la complexité
du lavoir de j une pierre dans le jardin
de la mairie
avec des périodes de gel et dégel tous
les ans on se dit que il va tomber et au
final il est toujours là donc on avait
quand même une technique de construction
je pense qu'ils étaient assez
remarquable même si c'est aussi une de
ses particularités ses qui date des
années 1900 il a été construit un petit
peu avant 1900 et il est construit en
ciment donc ce sont les premiers ciment
finalement de l'époque
il n'y a que deux lavoirs de forme
dodécagonale en france celui de j ai un
autre dans l'allier ce qui frappe ici ce
sont les 40 bac pour brosser et sur tous
les murs pleins pour protéger les
laveuses du vent pour cacher aussi la
marque d'une certaine pauvreté
l'hôtel des bavarde disaient les hommes
qui ne m'était jamais les mains dans
l'eau comprenez chacune bulckaen il
faudra acheter une pour laver
et avait dit il y avait des ragots
qu'ils disent il était avec les
brouettes
l'hiver on avait du show parce que on
faisait bouillir le loge
alors on avait les lessiveuses union
avait froid ont trompé les mains dans la
lessive
pas de machine à laver une première
étude réalisée en l'an 2000 évaluée à
500 mille euros le coût de la
restauration
l'argent ne coule pas entre les doigts
de la commune mais madame le maire a
tout de même relancer les devis que
voit-elle désormais dans le miroir de
l'eau on pourrait imaginer assez
facilement une galerie par exemple
d'exposition on a quand même pas mal de
pâtre je pense amateurs dans la commune
ça pourrait facilement d'être un lieu de
déambulation pourquoi pas imaginer va
remettre en eau par exemple bassin
central la commune veut frapper à toutes
les portes pour restaurer ce mal aimé de
l' architecture en béton lui qu'il n'y a
pas si longtemps était à sa façon le
nombril du village